die leute sagen allerdings auch das wird
dieser minecraft kinofilm der wohl bald
kommen wird noch ein bisschen braucht
und zwar braucht er
servus und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft hot spielen wir -
rudolf playmate i-punkt net m lover
internet habe ich sogar und ich hab
coole neuigkeiten für euch
und zwar habe ich gerade eben heute
erfahren hat mir echten zuschauer
bescheid gegeben dass wohl was ziemlich
cooles zum thema minecraft momentan
passiert und ab läuft im hintergrund und
hab mir gedacht ich möchte euch das
nicht vorenthalten macht mal dazu ein
video für euch und zwar folgendermaßen
es ist scheinbar momentan geplant und
die planung wird immer konkreter
dass ein minecraft kinofilm produziert
werden soll
das ist an sich eigentlich schon mal
eine relativ krasse sache weil ich mir
auch gar nicht so direkt vorstellen kann
was er in minecraft kino für passieren
also was ist denn so die handlung von
minecraft die man da über die nachstellt
dazu kann ich euch heute einiges
erzählen denn ich hab da im hintergrund
ein paar seiten auf ein paar
informationen aber als allererstes
wirklich mal interessieren was haltet
ihr eigentlich davon so minecraft
kinofilm ist das was cooles muss das
sein oder ist das jetzt absoluter
verlauten die wollen nur an das geld der
leute oder könnte das wirklich was
taugen was sie wie sie ihr da schreibt
man das noch mal die kommentare
ich will jetzt einfach ein bisschen mehr
weiter spielen und versuchen was zu dem
thema zu erzählen die haben jetzt auch
schon beschrieben bekannt gegeben
welcher regisseur das sein wird und zwar
die heißt bob mccann hänni ja ist es das
ist dass der typ das ist der name der
hier im artikel highlight ist mache ich
gucke dann ja ja die hatten davor einen
irgendein levy als regisseur
ja und der hat aber kein bock haft
irgendwie und dann haben sie jetzt ob
mac r hänni wohl als regisseur
eingestellt nämlich so gut geschafft
sehr gut unter dieser kinofilm soll dann
irgendwann produziert werden
allerdings sagen sie auch dass es wohl
noch ein wenig dauern wird bis diese
minecraft kinofilm dann auch tatsächlich
in die kinos kommt wahrscheinlich war
das relativ viel aufwand ist ein ding zu
zu produzieren
wenn wir jetzt zum thema story kommt
solle ich glaube so wie ich das gelesen
hab soll es einfach die ganz klassische
minecraft story sein also die die story
jemand startet quasi in der welt die
komplett unbebaut ist und baut sich dann
immer weiter und hat quasi so eine art
technologischen fortschritte nehmen auf
holz werkzeuge steinwerkzeuge folgen und
so wissen wir dass abläufe in minecraft
und dann das ziel und der klimax der
ganzen geschichte nur homo wird wohl
dieses mal nämlich das wird schon noch
raus wird wohl sein dass der protagonist
dann gegen den ender drachen kämpft ihr
in dem es nicht was die hier gerade so
veröffentlich haben wir den knappen
informationen steht halt irgendwas von
irgend ein drachen weil die leute keine
ahnung was ein ändert rache ist aber ich
vermute mal wenn sie sagen der drache
meinen sie den ender drachen ist
eigentlich auch nur ganz ganz witzige
sache aber sehr schlüssig finde ich oder
das macht ja sinn weil man das ist ja
auch so bist du die minecraft story auch
wenn mittlerweile des bisschen
vergessenheit geraten ist durch die
ganzen online spielmodi
er ist es im singleplayer so dass du
quasi machen kann zwar quasi machen was
du willst aber sobald du ins ende geht
und gegen den ender drachen kämpfen und
ihn besiegt krieg so viele
erfahrungspunkte
aber dann ist das das ding auch irgendwo
bei deswegen verstehe ich das gut
nachvollziehen dass das ja die story ist
seit so gut und lass mich mal nicht
runterfallen hallo hallo ich habe jetzt
hier ein paar quellen ich werfe nicht so
war
hier öffnen das ist hier ein hier die
leute sagen allerdings auch dass dieser
minecraft kinofilm der wohl bekommen
wird noch ein bisschen brauch und zwar
braucht er voraussichtlich
drei bis vier jahre steht hier in diesem
artikel bisher in die kinos kommt gut
drei bis vier jahre ist jetzt echt
numbers und was in drei bis vier jahren
mit minecraft los ist weiß wirklich
niemand aber es ist eigentlich ist schon
mal eine interessante perspektive man
kann ja sich jetzt schon mal überlegen
ob man sowas auch noch cool findet also
sollten braucht man sowas kann man sich
jetzt fragen braucht die menschheit
einen minecraft kinofilm ich persönlich
kann das nicht beurteilen was heißt
braucht braucht auch eine blöde frage
beim einkauf ist ja unterhaltung
ein kinofilm ist genauso unterhaltung
ist jetzt nicht so dass minecraft
irgendwie krebs ja auf jeden fall diesen
regisseur dazu könnt ihr noch was sagen
sunny in philadelphia
da hat er wohl mit ge wird dann schon
mal drüben ja diese story ist schauen
wie recht die klassische minecraft story
und dieser bob mccann hänni ist wohl der
maca den sie sich da ausgesucht haben
für diesen film
ich versuche ja immer ein bisschen
weiter zu kommen halo ist okay der das
kommt mir jetzt hier noch do list gucken
ich gucke da hab ich irgendwie übersehen
aber diesem artikel war ich euch
natürlich dass möglichst umfassendes
bild geben möchte
aber wie gesagt ich würde echt mal
interessieren warum ich dieses ding und
nimmer sehe das auch echte gemeinplatz
ihr da unten
wenn man einfach so gerade durchläuft
man dass ich einmal keine chance zu
sehen
nur wenn man darum dreht ich glaube ich
habe wieder richtig viele kisten auch
vergessen weil ich weiß gar nicht welche
module ich bin jetzt also das modul 6
oder so und ich habe wenn ich keine
brauchbare rüstung erhalten
das eigentlich nicht so geil
die dem artikel wird auch ein bisschen
mein facebook hat gewinnen kann es sein
das schreiben wir auch so ein bisschen
das minecraft ja so ein super hätte also
da sieht man auch schon dass diese
verfilmung schon stark kommerzielles
interesse hat also die machen das nicht
weil sie sich minecraft zu cool finden
sondern die machen das weise damit
hoffen irgendwie ein berg asche zu
verdienen deswegen muss man auch
vorsichtig sein
ich plädiere auch immer dafür dass die
youtuber den leuten die heute nicht nur
halten sondern auch was sinnvolles
erzählen deswegen würde ich euch sagen
leute jetzt zum beispiel thema minecraft
film seid nicht so naiv zu glauben dass
menschen minecraft film machen weil die
irgendwie minecraft cool finden gerade
irgendwelche random keine ahnung ist das
jetzt ein hollywood-regisseur oder
irgendwelche regisseure alter modul 10
und ich habe nichts ich habe so viele
kisten vergessen sondern ist es wirklich
so dass die leute halt geld verdienen
wollen deswegen macht euch das bewusst
und geht vielleicht nicht nur deshalb in
den filmen weil es irgendwie minecraft
kinofilm ist oder weil ich jetzt als
youtuber darüber rede sondern überlegt
euch überlegt euch vielleicht macht es
wirklich sinn in so einem film zu gehen
oder könnt ihr die keine ahnung wieviel
10 euro oder so wenn es wahrscheinlich
so ein 3d film zeit könnt ihr euch die
zehn euro
vielleicht besser investieren zum
beispiel in dem ja ich weiss nicht eure
oberflächen geschenk macht oder eurer
mutter generell dass außer den ich finde
dass mütter generell einfach viel zu
schlecht behandelt werden aber ja es ist
hier mal leicht zu der person die einem
sagt dass unser zimmer aufräumen soll
nicht so sein dass ich das geht mir
immer noch so ein ich bin schon 19 okay
wir können aber schnell findet ihr sie
natürlich
ich habe so viele kisten übersehen leute
ich wette mit euch
so die extreme aber noch ich schwöre
euch ich muss aber mal gucken dass in
grafite befinde
so soll er ist einfach nicht mal
annähernd so weit gekommen wie ich dann
hat 1000 besseres equipment leipzig
gefehlt
ok krass comcom ok habe ich einfach was
man sieht ist es das war jetzt richtig
ärgerlich verschwendung
ich hätte das nicht machen sollen der mg
lauft dann immer so rückwärts und will
die leute noch bogen von ihr fernhalten
aus funktion einfach nicht so gut
das ist eine sache die ich eigentlich ab
gewinnen sollte oha warum jetzt ich okay
aber habe ich den fans zurück bekommen
dank dem tippen sie bitte nicht zu viel
wollen die leute nicht to vima
nein nein das war nicht drei leute halt
das war sogar drei wie wall street view
wollen
hohmann leiter das finde ich echt
bisschen doof jetzt gerade habe ich
irgendwas besonderes was mich als als
leichtes ziel aussehen lässt war da was
den kampf von mir gibt's da war es jetzt
muss ich aber echt auf passiert noch ein
leben als zweithäufigste eigentlich also
bis an die wand fest ackern
jetzt hab ich damit wiederholen nee nee
der kommt schon wieder davon hätten
newiger nein
ihr seid doch alle nur geil auf die
fucking die akkus ist es machen ich will
einfach nur mal wie man kämpfen ja klar
nein man was für ein ruhiges deathmatch
alter kein einziges mal gegen einzigen
gegner gehabt immer 2 gegen mich richtig
bitter aber gut nicht so schlimm leute
ich denke mal dass das thema trotzdem
echt spannend ist und wie gesagt
schreibt gerne mal auch mal dazu in die
kommentare
und vergessen wir auf diese stadt möchte
ganz schnell wieder das war nicht von
mir das war
von martin g